I paid a lot of money for this name
today the table was flipped on you
you've been interviewing people on your
own podcast and Hannigan's for a bit but
today you're on Jessica's podcast is it
weird to go back and forth like that no
it's fun to be able to come in and just
have someone else ask all the questions
Vanderpump rules star scheana Marie Shay
hit up the podcast 1 studios in Beverly
Hills two guests on a Big Brother alum
Jessica graphs a new show know what I'm
in the process of freezing my eggs right
now so I'm going on like 40 days no no
hard liquor no weed you got into a lot
of stuff including the kind of big life
choice you're making right now losing
your age yeah it was something that I
thought about a couple years ago
actually when I was still married I
thought about freezing embryos because I
just knew where our relationship was
that at that time we were not in a place
that we were gonna have kids anytime
soon and then a few months after that we
ended up actually getting divorced so
it's been on my mind for the last
two-and-a-half years I just didn't have
time to do it until now it's like okay
you know what now's the time I'm doing
it now if I don't do it now I'm never
gonna do it I'm gonna keep talking about
it so I just woke up one day stop birth
control and decided I'm doing this now
for me it's been really easy and I don't
know if that's every woman's experience
but I don't have a fear of needles I
have 17 tattoos and I get Botox every
three months so for me the shots have
not been hard I was more nervous about
the hormones and how I was gonna feel I
thought I would be depressed crying
myself to sleep every night and I've
been fine I just want to keep putting it
out there that if you can afford it and
you know you're under 35 like absolutely
do it because I would never regret doing
this I would regret not doing it having
the option to already have my eggs on I
set you know if I do want kids and what
if I can't carry it myself I can still
have a biological child if I choose to
and if I don't find the right guy and
that doesn't work out then you know what
I get to travel the world and have them
on ice for whatever for forever but no
weed no drinking no fun during this
period of time it sound
I mean I still have some fun but it's
just been hanging out like Netflix and
chilling literally because I'm also cut
off of that right now
but um it's it's been a great experience
and I am planning on doing it again in a
few months because my doctor said eggs
are like money you can never have too
much or too money so so Netflix and
chilling right now we heard you talking
on the podcast about hanging in bang in
so we're not doing the bangin part right
now oh just the hanging making out and
hanging doesn't sounded fun we're back
in high school right seriously I feel
like I'm in junior high right now not
even high school like junior high but
we've been watching you hang and not
bang on Vanderpump rules - you have a
couple guys in the mix i'ma or watch on
the show and you're dating them but
you're not getting a homerun with them
I'm gonna take a quick shower you're
welcome to join me oh yeah thanks Adam
doesn't give me sex what's happening
keep watching there was there was
someone else in the picture at the time
who didn't want to film so I was getting
that just not from the people who agreed
to be on camera
okay that's what some things into
perspective because I'm like it looks
like it's like no one else leave Roisin
out I'm like no I was they just didn't
want to be on camera I will just say
it's not a storyline runer that was the
first last and only scene you will ever
see Robby Hazen on Vanderpump rules
why do you think I won't sleep with you
because you're not attracted to me oh
yeah that ended sorry but you'll see a
lot more to come with me and Adam and no
I didn't mean that
[Laughter]
[Music]